pour la 17e édition d'armes année le
marché international d'art contemporain
47 artistes ont présenté leurs oeuvres
parmi eux isabelle masson cet artiste
peinte n'a pas fait d'école d'art elle
est autodidacte
j'aime l'univers un peu sourd science
fiction et surtout j'aime les peintures
en mouvement donc j'aime l'art
contemporain aussi donc c'est pour ça
que mes oeuvres elles sont organisées
autour des villes modernes et des
planètes qui bouge cet artiste local est
déjà venue lors de précédentes éditions
c'est une première pour d'autres venus
de plus loin
30% d'artistes locaux on a aussi cette
année donc 30% de nouveaux artistes qui
se sont fait connaître par le bouche à
oreille est également particulièrement
cette année on a deux artistes écossais
qui sont dues au travers du comité de
jumelage de guyancourt
c'est la nouveauté de ce salon stuart
harper agent est venu faire la promotion
de deux artistes écossais seul espoir
que sa paille à pitre le petit score ses
oeuvres ont été réalisés par peter scott
il a peint dans sa région d'enfance qui
est dans le nord de la côte aberdyn ce
sont des paysages de son enfance il
séjourné là bas avec sa famille pendant
les vacances c'est son enfance qu'il a
reproduit à travers ses tableaux
c'est un aspect personnel mais aussi
historique de l'appareil
un rendez vous où les fonds récoltés
vont à des associations
nous avons remis harman et un chèque de
2000 euros qui correspondait à un peu
hauts revenus de la de l'année dernière
donc c'était surtout sur la maltraitance
le lion's-club soutient également deux
autres causes le handicap et alzheimer
depuis 2014 cet artiste soutien c'est
cause en participant harman et elle
travaille le plastique et le carton avec
des techniques différentes
je trouve que c'est très important de
pouvoir faire quelque chose
d'être à la fois que l'art soit
d'utilité publique pour la future
édition harman et espère s'ouvrir encore
à l'international mille visiteurs ont
déambulé dans les allées du salon durant
le week end